basé sur la terminologie des échecs
queen it 157 est un avion lourd puissant
mais il y a un chiffre plus léger qui
ou un cheval utilisé pour
attaques ici nous sommes tellement associatifs
c'est ainsi que s'appelait cet avion
pourquoi utiliser cette terminologie
parce que l'avion est rapide
Il a une vitesse de Mach 18, soit environ
1900 kilomètres par heure, il a un puissant
armes
peut transporter plus de sept mille
tonnes de charge utile, c'est-à-dire
armes bombes et missiles tous différents
type plus il aura aussi
canon qui peut aussi être utilisé
c'est-à-dire que c'est un avion assez puissant et
en même temps c'est léger